I'm just I'm trying to figure out the
logic of all of this the timing of all
of this why on a Saturday and that's why
we're bringing in Mike Florio from pro
football talk and NBC football night in
America Mike good morning thanks for
joining us why now
that's a great question Dan because look
some people think it's a PR move by the
NFL to do this well why would you do it
now everything's done everything's over
Kaepernick's agent put out a memo a few
weeks ago addressing some of the false
narratives it's still linger about Colin
Kaepernick it didn't even register a
blip on the radar screen people don't
care people have moved on I don't know
why the league would decide right now we
got to have this workout on a Saturday
in November where all teams are going to
be invited no one's gonna be there I
mean they'll send low-level lackeys to
cover this thing and maybe a coach in a
GM oh look at the film of it but a
workouts not meaningful unless the coach
is there the GM is there they're not
going to be there and that's why
Kaepernick's agents said initially the
league can we do it on Tuesday the
league said no well can we do it next
Saturday so teams have more time to do
this league says no so there's a weird
vibe to this there's something else
going on more than meets the eye
any team out there can bring him in for
a workout anytime they want the idea of
the league office has decided out of the
blue we're gonna have this workout where
all 32 teams are invited and it's going
to be this Saturday and only this
Saturday there's just something about it
that doesn't smell right and if it's PR
it's clumsy PR Dan I think at a certain
level they're worried about a second
lawsuit from Colin Kaepernick for
retaliating against him because of the
first one you know he follows the first
one they pay him and then they continue
to freeze him out the argument now would
be the reason no one's giving him a job
is they're upset they had to write him a
big check and as we see these fringe
level quarterbacks who are thriving why
does that this guy even get a workout he
doesn't even get a phone call and this
is the NFL's possibly possibly clumsy
way of enhancing their legal standing if
there is a second lawsuit somewhere down
the road from Kaepernick what's more
important on Saturday the actual workout
with Kaepernick or the interview with
Kaepernick I think the workouts more
important Dan because look these teams
have been in position to find out
everything they want to find out how
much money does he want what's he
expecting that
have treated him like he doesn't exist
they don't want to know the answers to
the questions they've allowed the false
narratives to take root and there are
people who say well he wants 20 million
a year well he only wants to be a
starter well he's a vegan
well he's this yeah and and these are
easy questions to get answers to if they
want them but it's been crickets for two
and a half years and really the best
argument that the teams have now to stay
away from him is the fact that he hasn't
played since January 1 of 2017 and the
reason he hasn't played since then is
because they successfully frozen him out
so that's what's so strange about this
they're at a point where everyone's
moved on and everyone's accepted I've
been a cavernous reporter from day one
and I've accepted he's not getting back
in it is so bizarre to me that all of a
sudden they would do this but yeah we'll
see and who's gonna be there to
interview him that's the thing if a
coach at a GM isn't there and they send
some low-level scout how meaningful is
that interview going to be so the just
the whole thing stinks to me and and you
know I I'd love to know how this came to
be I'd love to know who's bright idea
this was I'd love to know how many
owners actually knew about this before
this is something the league office
decided to do I had a source who told me
this morning because I said where's this
coming from and its source said there's
pressure on the commissioner and I said
who's applying the pressure and he said
I can't talk about it now what the hell
is going on here I mean it's a jzi Sims
and I were talking about this earlier
damn PFT live and Sims throughout the
jay-z angle and my thought is if jay-z
was in any way responsible for this that
would have been leaked because he's
gonna want credit for us to push back
against all the criticism he got so if
no one's linking jay-z to this it's not
jay-z so I don't know where the pressure
would be on the commissioner unless the
pressure is coming from his in-house
lawyer Jeff pash saying we need to do
something here we needed weight no one's
giving this guy a workout we need to we
need to have a workout for him and maybe
he won't show up but if he doesn't show
up and we can say he's really not
serious about playing football and it
may be that it's just his weird game of
chess that they're they're gonna throw
the enforcers they're gonna throw these
bread crumbs out there and see if he
follows the trail and if he doesn't then
they put themselves in a better spot if
there would be further litigation down
the road but this one is one of the more
bizarre developments it's you know it's
unforced error from the league at a time
when they want everyone to focus on the
100 season they're the ones who have
dusted this off and put this front and
center and there was no reason to do it
if I gave you one question privately for
Colin Kaepernick what would you ask him
I'd want to know will he accept coming
in and taking a veteran minimum salary
and being a member of the depth chart
there to compete and prepare and and
just and you know and and just work and
just go to work and not expect anything
other than a spot on the team with an
opportunity to show in practice what he
can do and because really what can you
do on the fly you're trying to change
the tire on a moving car if you come in
playing quarterback the only place where
it would make sense is Baltimore where
Greg Roman is the offensive coordinator
let me tell you if Lamar Jackson gets
injured they better call Colin
Kaepernick because then it's down to RG
three and if they want to finish out
this special season they have going and
Jackson does get injured Kaepernick is
the only thing that's going to keep this
on track for the Baltimore Ravens great
stuff Mike thank you we appreciate your
time as always i dancey buddy that's
Mike Florio Pro Football Talk live
co-host and NBC football night in
America for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]